sepeda mentioned it that he's afraid for
four fights
i think there's a lesson for all of us
human beings out there
just in all walks of life subpoena
fighter where a lot of times we take for
granted we assume i know there's an old
saying
when you assume something you make a out
of me
right and you know you should never
assume
but we do we see a fighter we say oh
they're not afraid they're born
different they
feel different they no they're afraid
and sopeda made that clear he said no
i'm i'm not only afraid i'm unsure of
myself i
i doubt myself i don't believe in myself
sometimes
he didn't act like a guy who didn't
believe in himself and
for all the people out there what i'm
trying to say is it doesn't matter how
you feel
what matters is what you make yourself
do
we all feel scared even great fighters
even great fighters we all feel scared
but if we can put that
over here and have the
discipline and commitment to what we're
doing and prepare
ourselves to do that we can perform
despite of those feelings and perform
greatly
and get great things done it's done
every day it's done every day in the
ring
it's done every day outside the ring by
people
and i want to remind the guy out there
there's somebody out there watching this
that's saying gee i'm not sure myself i
don't think i can
yeah you can yeah you can you just got
verification buddy
from this guy who just fought this fight
that we made a special broadcast for
because it was so special he just said
he wasn't sure himself
he didn't believe in himself sometimes
he's scared and what did he do
he went in there and did everything that
you need to do
to be a winner and he and
he faced what he had to face despite
feeling that way
and it's a lesson for all of us that you
don't have to be a fighter to do that
all in a fight life is a fight
and um you just you just want to not
give in
to those feelings fill them they make
you ready
they put you on edge use it
but make the choice at the end what
you're gonna do it's your choice it's
nobody else's choice
and the big reason i brought up the the
movie
was i thought of saving private ryan it
was a great movie with tom hanks i don't
know if you saw it ken
yep but it's a classic i think it won
some awards actually
and it's it's a horrible movie and
at the end of the day all the things
they just said
sir pater the winner goes over to baran
check and he said something to him
and barantak says something to him
and it kind of made me think about that
movie that
movie because at the end when
everyone all the soldiers in that movie
put
it all on the line and their leader tom
hanks i don't know if he was a captain
lieutenant sergeant probably sergeant
whatever he was he was the boss he was
the leader
he put it all on the line with them and
he was
he was he got mortally wounded
and as he was having his last few
breaths
and you knew he was gonna he was gonna
die
and um he says
to private ryan
the guy who fought with him who he saved
who who went on
he said to him make it worthwhile
make your life worthwhile live a good
life
and it made me think almost a little bit
like that like it was almost like
baran check was saying to sepeda
make it worthwhile go win the title
make everything that i put out here this
effort that i put out here to bring you
to a higher level
to to let you show something that you
never showed before
let it be worthwhile don't let it be
wasted
use it that's all i just wanted to say
those words
uh to our audience out there something
to think about
um you know these are the situations
right here that
you know it takes me back to me when i
used to tell my wife before i got into
the ring i said tell her all the time
you know look at me now the man that you
see right now
is not going to be the same man that
exits the ring tonight
so take take a deep breath in and look
at me
you know because that's that's truly it
you know barranchi
a piece of him was left in the ring
tonight
a piece of him was left and he'll never
get
it back those are deep words coming from
the former world champion tim bradley
both guys left something in the ring
tonight yes they did the peda
as well but he was fortunate enough to
land the shot that ended the fight in
such a brutal fashion
and like we said i mean this is boxing
this was boxing at its finest this was
boxing at its best
this was boxing with two warriors giving
their all
this is what they came to do tonight yes
congratulations this was the greatest
win of your career
but it was a frightening end what are
you feeling right now
well you know i feel great because i won
the fight uh
it was a hard fight and um
i mean i'm thinking man boxing it's it's
hard man it's no easy game
boxing it's it's tough and you got to
give it 100
because uh it's it's it's a it's a hard
sport
it's probably the hardest sport what did
you tell ivan at the end
thank you uh uh thank you for the
opportunity i mean both of us were
both those are climbing up and and
somebody had to stay you know
and down so
i was able to win the fight and i told
him you know thanks for the fight great
great fight
great was a great fight you were down
four times
and won by knockout did you think you
had that in you
you know i i know i know i i know i was
tough
i know i'm tough i didn't know how tough
i was and and
well tonight tonight i show and and i
show myself too
and you know it's the first time i'm in
a fight like this and it was it was it
was a
great learning experience you showed the
best thing that was in your heart
your soul it was uh some of it was
difficult to watch but
what would you take with you from this
to be honest i have to watch the fight
again uh but i think
just just believe in myself you know
it's it's it's it's too in there
it's two two guys in there giving their
all and at the end of the day i think
it's whoever wants it more
be honest with me as best you can
you doubted yourself at times going into
this fight did you not
i i all the time to be honest it happens
to me all the time in
every fight i doubt myself too much
i'm a fighter that only had 16 amateur
fights
you know not a lot of experience in
amateur
so i'm always doubting myself and uh
this fight yeah it was it was tough